[Music]
this episode brought to you by Mack
Weldon with smart designs premium
fabrics and easy shopping is probably
better than what you're wearing right
now
[Music]
there's a cinematic battle that has been
waging for years two opposing sides that
seemed eerily similar yet drastically
different they will not stop until they
are victorious or get bored it's been
happening right under our noses for
years and most important to know it's
all happening right up here and of
course talk about the battle between the
jock side of your brain and the
intellectual side of your brain they're
constantly in battle even if you're not
aware of it oftentimes they disagree
that in the previous 27 was amazing yeah
I was a part of all that awesome
shithead Alto all of it yeah once again
the story and characters make absolutely
no sense and it was just an excuse for
pointless stuff
you shut your ass yeah don't make me
throw her at you yeah I cooked sometimes
they get along
Captain America's Civil War had dead
insight and concepts yes spider-man yeah
yeah every once in a while to get that
movie which neither side knows what to
think is it too dumb not dumb enough
trying too hard not even trying one of
those films is alien versus Predator
based off the alien movie series on the
predator movie series this idea
surprisingly has been buzzing around for
a while when predator to show the head
of an alien mounted fans immediately
start to speculate about what a
crossover would be like there were fan
arts comics even videogames hey that's
the case where's my Terminator vs.
Robocop actually don't do that finally
in 2004 after the success of Freddy vs.
Jason we got our cross horror over well
certainly nobody sees as the best alien
or predator movie the reaction still
seemed to be all over the map some love
it
some hate it some say it's just good
enough others say it's just bad now
maybe I was a little concerned when I
saw with directed by Paul WS Anderson
you know the guy whose movies ranges
from him to back port Duke can never get
an R rating when he needed the most and
even when he does it gets trimmed out
because it was 2r for an R rating or so
faith that's pretty much just a pg-13 in
disguise
exactly alien vs. predator movie this
pg-13 bullshit but it does try and build
character and suspense like the others
yes that's just what goes into all that
pointless fighting that becomes
pedestrian you're kidding me that's all
the best stuff in the movie you see it's
surprisingly hard to get a grasp on
unlike the new alien movies which
everyone can strangely enough agree to
disagree
oh yes those movies are beyond tired and
predictable why are you still making
those actually we think those movies are
okay why are they still making those so
let's see what's on your brain you end
up agreeing with this is alien vs.
predator we open with the sound many
people make while watching this movie ah
as part of course we've seen this alien
movie takes place in the future of 2004
insert a media confusion it's done yeah
it's never really explained why this
takes place during present day
especially when the alien movies they
make it clear Ripley's team are the
first humans to encounter them found
something never recorded once in over
300 surveyed world it's been circled
that this movie is not canon to either
film series which I guess is fine it
looks like they just want thrown some
badass fighting without confused
people with continuity plans interest in
playing Charles Bishop Whelan who runs a
company that builds robots that look
just like him in the future but dies in
this movie ok so this current reality
will make about as much sense as our
current reality so let's just get to the
cool cliches we all secretly kind of
love like the introduction of our lead
Alexa who we know is badass because
she's introduced in the ultimate badass
cliched introduction of climbing a
mountain yeah that neatly shows you're
tough when you show that's what you do
in your off time really it's not a big
deal I just do this for fun
look I carry mountains in my pocket it's
so not a big deal that she can even take
a phone call asking her to go on the
next petition it off to fund the
foundation which you are Thursday April
Fool here is so not a big deal to the
people on the other end because they're
already at the top of the mountain
waiting for her all these big cool
things are so not being cool things to
them that they don't even question the
plausibility of them we're just gonna
sneak a helicopter on top of a mountain
silently so that the climber never
notices there's really no reason it'll
just be an awesome reveal like I said no
big deal cuz were badass meanwhile in
Mexico everyone gathers around an
archaeologist who hasn't found anything
yet to discover he hasn't found anything
yet hey one of these days that's gonna
lead to world peace but Weyland
industries is so impressed with his
ability to do his job poorly they'd
flown out to the same mission as Alexa
as well as Ellen simon pegg coming here
I'm documenting you except for my voice
this is it
they especially love how not dead I am
yep I guess you could say that's my
character having a family and not being
dead I said the long future for me they
all meet up at Weyland industries where
mr. Weyland explains their mission
several feet above them from behind
that's kind of douchey seven days ago
one of my satellites over Antarctica on
incremental deposits discovered a sudden
heat militia we turn our chairs around
the red lines in the game solid walls
through the thermal happen generative
stage right over there and our Nexus
starting to hurt one expert tells me
this has features reminiscent of the
Aztecs you don't need the microphone
with like 15 of a planet dangers
expedition came to plant talking to us
more about the people my experts tell me
it's a pyramid mostly because a shape on
comparemaine my pyramid experts told me
that naturally a disturbance has
occurred in the Arctic that Whelan wants
looked at right away but Alexa thinks
they don't have enough time to do it
right and walks out find another guy no
really guys she told not going we shot
all the footage of her just so she could
come in and say no she's so angry she's
not even gonna show her breath in
freezing cold weather one space left in
the world that no one else come on don't
let me go up pictures of my kids icky in
case you forgot kids and not being dead
that's whatever my name is do we stand a
better chance of surviving with you with
a number two choice
I mean we saw how you treat your own
offspring clearly you're a tough bitch
she of course eventually agrees and they
get ready to head out I'm laying down
three simple rules one no one goes
anywhere alone to everyone must maintain
constant communication three if this is
your first night you have to fight I'd
rather have one and not need it than
need it and not have one I'm glad that
you decided to stay
YouTube's future courts with no identity
I'm just calling Jane Lynch :
[Music]
now did you have to hand it to mr.
Anderson for trying to establish mood
through beautiful cinematography as well
as characters you surprisingly don't
want to see their necks broken into
people yeah but we're really adverse
across yeah every once in a while show
some watching but the longest time
they're doing yeah we could do that we
are doing that I think movie but us to
the movie does take a while to get going
but in the first two films we hit
characters we enjoyed hanging with
amazing real as well as likeable here
Alexa is pretty cool and even exchanges
a nice conversation with Henriksen we
think that's the last thing your dad
remembers hey or drinking champagne with
his daughter 14,000 feet in the air but
everyone else is just accent oh I sure
hope Mexican accent doesn't die before
Scottish accent but at least we would
still have telling you there's no team
and no machine the world that get cut to
this depth in 24 hours whatever the hell
that's trying to be I'm going to say
adorable they journey through the ruins
of Winstone and credits where they
partake in their favorite game fake-out
shunning looks that was pretty good but
surely there's a better one behind the
corner I'm sorry that doesn't count
unless you make a Chun with every step
you take I would kill if that penguin
took the role of a cat in the series
help we can give it its own animated
spin-off with a surprise ending why am I
the only one to see the possibilities
here there's a pretty cool show and the
predator ship passes over them literally
without making a sound
in fact it actually goes more quiet when
it passes over
whoa okay that was pretty cool but it's
followed by our hero's new ping around
in the dark a day I don't know why these
movies always go with this setup it's
been done too many times we know most of
them are going to die and it's not
really a mystery of what's out there you
could argue it's to showcase the gore
but pg-13 you know you're not going to
get that it's not even any of the main
characters that get axed off first it's
a bunch of extras surprise the predator
vision doesn't look like this my keeo
they're evil they found a way to combine
the Virtual Boy and the power glove into
one these Predators really do know how
to make bombs so it looks like the
Predators actually captured a queen
alien and have relate facehuggers to
grow in humans and be hunted by them
either that or now can't bury eggs have
a reason for tasing bad that's right I
said it alot to pay to may I guess I
mean collosum for the Predators to do
that because our human character sure as
hell aren't a lot of fun to kill off all
right we went from Schwarzenegger to us
take a stall Frank we don't want to
tickets cause you tickets Klein neither
of us will take a scull well just let
time kill em and piss on it corpse hi
I'm ty point speaker shut up Frank our
appetizers tumble across
fog machines for the Predators ancient
ritual of running a haunted garage any
idea what these are oh you know it's a
good tune people the experts hey they're
only good at figuring out that pyramid
shapes their pyramid how the hell they
supposed to figure out what gun shapes
are oh yeah it's a good thing cuz this
it's like plain to Moses DVD collection
so first really weird line of the movie
took a while but else that finally dumb
this is like plain to Moses DVD
collection sorry that line was so dumb
it's literally killing me
we'll run for the Testing Service know
the destination yeah after staring at
them for almost three minutes only now
does he say don't touch him that should
be minimum sentence number two Wow look
at these touch when we're dead
this of course signals the Predators to
hunt them down as they display
holy shit gremlin cocoons this movie
just got a billion extra points no of
course it's the facehuggers who jump in
slow-mo as you can tell a fake they are
and impregnate our victims pretty fast
considering it's usually a day or two
process in the original and now it's
only a few minutes even the chest burst
doesn't seem like that big a deal
anymore all the other times it's
horrific downward disturbing but here
oh that's annoying come on Ian just got
you're shaped like a dick doesn't you
have to act like one okay I'm only
giving you two stars on Yelp and that's
because I actually want yeah but you get
one more star if you sing hello my baby
[Applause]
[Music]
hello does Walker here interrupting your
commercial for a well commercial I
noticed you were eyeing my shirt my sexy
body does look amazing it but believe it
or not my body is not that sexy
I know I know Iowa shocked too but
that's the power of Mack Weldon selling
premium fabrics and shirts undershirts
underwear socks sweatpants even hoodies
they even have a silver line of clothing
that lemonade's odor so it's great for
working out in which again to get a body
this sexy I will consider watching
somebody they make online shopping so
easy and simple to navigate I love mac
welding so much I didn't just buy one
shirt I bought however many that was in
fact if you go to Mac well done calm and
use the promo wear critic you get 20%
off and for some reason you don't like
your first pair you can keep it and they
still refund your money no questions
asked so yes sexy can happen overnight
or take you either way Mac welding is
there to help check them out and see
what you're missing
[Music]
[Applause]
meanwhile everyone either gets Tetris to
death or separately
oh no not whatever accent he was I miss
the way he existed but the Predators
also seemed to want their guns back
bullshit I am NOT dying via net in an
alien vs. predator movie I refuse to go
out this way that's a little better two
stars on yellow predator and alien
finally meet and shit gets shaky
again it's weird when you can see it
it's friggin awesome it even has a fair
amount of practical effects mixed with
the CG but when it's shaking it isn't
rendered right it's not talked okay now
jump to the part we use the alien as a
pinball tilt after the sphere but after
one predator gets act another one goes
after the humans seeing how Henriksen
has asthma he doesn't even bother with
him what Hendrickson still has something
to prove
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
joke's on you I'm still now can end up -
- morelia movies I will admit it is a
shame that the film is only pg-13 yeah
but for a pg-13 movie they got away with
a lot though I'm confused
does making the blood green make it
somehow less gore no I think it just
makes it a Christmas movie that's
Christmas movies that die hard yeah
[Applause]
sadly though we go from one awesome
fighting scene to a whole shit ton of
explaining ancient warriors would work
themselves these hunters found a
backwater planet and where worship
discuss humans were used to breed the
ultimate prey if the hunters lost they
made sure nothing survived heat Bloom
was designed to rest down here nobody
cares
we don't need to know what they marked
themselves we can figure it out
obviously it's a predator temple they're
plastered all over the place and it's
pretty clear they breathe the aliens to
husband because we know that's what they
enjoy so I'll say this there is one
thing they don't explain why I have a
temple at all why not just drop a few
eggs wait a year and then literally hunt
a planet of aliens wouldn't it be much
more challenging than a great vacation
spot for primitive families hey kids you
want to go to Planet dickhole you do
nothing but that big hole to have dick
holes in their dick holes we already
have a children's film for them to watch
afterwards how can nobody smell the
money oh by the way die emic die dead
dies to be fair it is good to know that
the guy that goes on and on about his
kids is killed off by another parents
kids kinda like a vegetarian being
trampled by a cow it's a little funny
you know what's not funny all this guy's
explaining when that door opens where
does during can be game hunter the
animals being hunted don't arm man
except Enoch or teen him to death thank
you
this means it's just Alexa left as she
confronts the last predator give him
back his gun and through honestly very
clever storytelling we're visually told
everything with no dialogue
she killed an alien winning his respect
they realized they have to work together
he shows her the alien skin is immune to
the acid blood so she uses the tail as a
spear and the head as a goddamn shield I
was in this movie about her what what do
you mean all the cool stuff is happening
now using alien armor alone badass you
can't just have a horror film with only
one person through most of it folks
actually he may have a point because the
movie is pg-13 the only goal
get is Rahman stirs and there's been
plenty of horror films to focus on one
person as long as the character is
interesting like she is that would
possibly work there being less filler
and dialogue and by focusing on only one
person it surprisingly had more human
interest and we get more what we want
alien versus Predator man because truth
be told the rest of the movie is hugely
entertaining the aliens help the queen
escape they find various ways to
outsmart and outrun it and they have to
do it all through communication that's
not verbal true sometimes it's resident
evil shows but it shot great the pacing
is better and it's nothing but the cool
badass characters left just being cool
badass characters she's it has to show
her loyalty by killing off one of her
friends because an alien is bursting out
of him showing she's not going soft and
she means business it's actually pretty
cool after they blow the entire temple
up which I'm sure means McQueen is
destroyed hey as long as this thing
doesn't pop up I'm good he marks her
making her a first-level awesome Nader
but naturally it's not quite over
we are act onions it's a three-way
battle between alien predator and human
and by God just saying that sentence was
amazing but they all get injured meaning
they have to take cover
quick will be often graveyard
the predator gets bad but I like the
launches between into the ocean naeli
her punk ass yeah I wish I could drown
it's gonna be a long life
yeah what's like other predators arrived
just in the nick of time but they see
she's an honorary brother and leave her
alone even giving her one other stats
for putting up an honorable fight Aaron
don't touch the red button that'll blow
up earth later but they should have ran
that body through customs because it
looks like you hearing some illegal
target wait a minute when did a face
hugger get him why would the Queen
attack him if he was impregnated why
would it mix with his DNA creating a new
creature it was cool so that was alien
versus Predator and even today it's
still kind of hard to get a grasp on in
so many ways it betrays what we want but
in so many other ways it delivers
exactly what we want it looks great
there are good fight teams and cool
moments and you know the worst parts
really aren't that bad especially when
you compare it to their other films it
sucks waiting through certain moments
but when you get to the fun stuff it is
a lot of fun I guess it depends on what
you're looking for
I'm personally glad I saw it it did give
me everything but they gave me enough so
while your inner jock and inner
intellect Duke it out hopefully you can
come to a conclusion about whether or
not this is we're here by no means the
best book I know means the worst it is
the Enigma that is alien versus Predator
there is one thing we can all agree on
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
this is like findin Moses DVD collection
hey everybody Doug Walker here during
the charity shout out and this week we
are doing the National Alliance of
mental illness this is the nation's
largest grassroots mental health
organization dedicated to building
better lives for the millions of
Americans affected by mental illness
what started as a small group of
families gathered around a kitchen table
in 1979 has blossomed into the nation's
leading voice on mental health today
they're an association of hundreds of
local affiliates state organizations and
volunteers who work in your community to
raise awareness and provide support and
education that was not previously
available to those in need
they provide volunteer leaders with the
tools resources and skills necessary to
save mental health in all states the
telephone helpline allows them to
respond personally to hundreds of
thousands of requests each year
providing free referral information and
support if you look at their site and
their youtube channel you can see how
serious mental health is and how much
needs to be dedicated to keep it in
check take a look at this wonderful
organization and see how you can make a
big difference not only in another
person's life but maybe yours as well
[Music]
you